what happened to bella twins hall of
famer
divas champion
after being away for three years brie
bella makes an epic return to wwe's
royal rumble and she made sure to have
this cutie by her side it feels really
good yep that's bree's daughter
four-year-old birdie whom she shares
with her husband brian danielson ahead
of getting into the ring the mom of two
shared photos on instagram of birdie
rocking a red birdie mode shirt inspired
by bree saying bree mode she captioned
the adorable pics of the little one
quote birdie is ready and so am i let's
get ready to rumble bree mode is
activated brie bella in full blown free
mode
the 38-year-old summed up her triumphant
return to wwe with her sister nikki
bella by sharing these behind the scenes
shots a birdie watching in anticipation
and cheering her on brie also shared
this heartwarming photo of her cuddled
next to birdie where you can see the two
are coordinating with their all red
outfits we love fashion and we love
being with our kids all the time lastly
fans got this epic shot of the
four-year-old playfully squaring up to
her mom in the ring bree captioned the
photos in part quote i might not have
won but my daughter told me i'm the
coolest superhero so that makes me feel
like i won in june of 2021 brie and
nikki bella opened up to e.t about
making an official return to wrestling
and having their kids there to see it
all
so we we definitely talk about it um you
know the one thing is that wwe brought
the women's tag team uh titles and we're
like wait a second how did the bellas
not have this on their resume so it's so
tempting because we would love to go
fight for the tag titles because that's
all we've ever been as a tag team and i
think another thing too is now that
birdie's four and we're talking about
when the boys get a little older too to
have your kids watch you do what we used
to do to get in that ring would be
really special for us i'll never forget
the moment when i wrestled stephanie
mcmahon at summerslam and to see her
three little girls they were little at
the time their faces when we came back
they looked at their mom like she was a
superhero and i was like i want that one
day i i just thought that was the
coolest thing and so
the bellas are definitely going to make
a comeback we don't know exactly when
but we said we have one more run in us
and we'd really love to do it
you